sugar is playing hide-and-seek with you
you'd think it would be pretty easy for
you to win considering all the sugar in
sodas ice cream candy and big white bags
labeled sugar people get about half of
their added sugars from those drinks and
treats so it might seem like sugar is
hiding in plain sight but like someone
in the witness protection program the
other half is hidden in places you'd
least suspect check the ingredients on
ketchup Bologna spaghetti sauce soy milk
sports drinks fish sticks and peanut
butter you'll find sugar hiding in most
of those products in fact you'll find
added sugars in three-quarters of the
more than 600,000 items available in
grocery stores but how is sugar hiding
can't you just look on food labels it's
not that easy just like your friend
Robert might go by Bob Robbie
Rob Bobby or Roberto added sugar has a
lot of aliases
and buy a lot we don't mean five or six
try 56 there's brown rice syrup barley
malt Demerara Florida Crystals Muscovado
and of course high fructose corn syrup
sometimes called HFCS or corn sugar even
sugars tricking nicknames have nicknames
grape or Apple concentrate has the same
effect on your body as it's 55 sugary
twins and even though organic evaporated
cane juice sounds healthy when you
evaporate it you get sugar chemically
speaking it's all the same and even
trickier when multiple added types of
sugars are used in one product they get
buried down in a long list of
ingredients so the sugar content might
appear to be okay but when you add them
all together sugar can be the single
biggest ingredient currently the FDA
doesn't suggest a recommended daily
limit for sugar so it's hard to tell if
the 65 grams on a bottle of soda is a
little or a lot but the World Health
Organization recommends limiting sugar
to just 5 percent of your total calories
or about 25 grams per day so 65 grams is
well over twice that amount but just
what is sugar what's the difference
between glucose and fructose well both
are
hydrates with the same chemical
composition of carbon hydrogen and
oxygen but they have very different
structures and behave quite differently
in our bodies glucose is the best source
of energy for nearly all organisms on
earth it can be metabolized by all
organs in the body
fructose on the other hand is
metabolized primarily in the liver and
when your liver gets overloaded with
sweet sweet fructose the excess is
metabolized to fat fresh fruits actually
contain fructose but it's naturally
occurring and doesn't cause an overload
because the fiber in fruit slows its
absorption this gives your liver the
time it needs to do its job
it's sugar that makes cookies chewy and
candy crunchy it even turns bread crust
a beautiful golden brown it's also a
great preservative it doesn't spoil or
evaporate so the foods it's added to are
easier to store and ship long distances
and tend to be cheaper that's why sugar
is hiding everywhere actually it might
be easier to list the foods that added
sugar isn't hiding in things like
vegetables eggs meats fish fruit raw
nuts even your kitchen sink simply
choosing water over soda juices and
sports drinks is a great way to avoid
hidden added sugar at the very least try
to pay attention to food labels so you
can keep your sugar intake at a healthy
level because in this game of
hide-and-seek every time you don't find
out it's sugar you win
you